Did I trick you? Because this is not as tricky as it may look initially. Okay, so this 10¹³ cell.
Let's figure out what the net charge on this cell is.
What each cell has 10¹⁵ protons? Okay, that will contribute some charge 10¹⁵ times
the charge per proton as 10¹⁵ neutrons, they don't contribute at all in 10¹⁵ electrons
which will contribute the exact same charge that the protons contributed but negative.
The positive charges in the protons will cancel the negative charges in the electrons
The net charge on the human body will be zero.
This explains why you don't feel the electric force everyday.
You're much more familiar with gravity because your body doesn't have a net charge.
You could stay in pretty close to a charged object and you wouldn't feel much of anything.
This may have just raised more questions than it answered because well, let's see,
if everything is neutral, why do we even care about charge?
How can we make something non-neutral? How can we give it a charge?
If lightning has electricity, well it seems like there's a whole lot of it moving around.
Where does that come from? Let's answer those questions.